just walk up say he looks like you do to  shoeshine  my name is mr. Lee our numbers be four  three eight seven zero a very tall six  six one and they can call you in  Bakersfield your mobile shoeshine you  can call me anytime anytime you're here  telling Tommy the hotel I'll come to  Banco tip i'ma call you come to the big  whoppers shine everyone's shoes love it  man hustle hustle  I bought my first car in 15 years old  she shined shoes and throw the San Jose  Mercury News paper on Saturdays and  Sundays I did that  so  I know the charge $70 $7 then you - so  you charge the seven but some people  give you ten okay how about I give you  $100  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  sure  you keep hustling relevant your messages  can impact a lot of people I love your  hustle the great story  keep that on